- [vomiting]
[toilet flushing]
- LIZ, IS IT SWIMSUIT SEASON?
- MM?
- 'CAUSE YOU JUST, LIKE,
RALPHED.
I COULD TELL THAT THERE WAS
SOMETHING WRONG WITH LIZ
'CAUSE WE'RE LIKE TWINS.
PEOPLE MISTAKE US
FOR ONE ANOTHER ALL THE TIME
AND NOT JUST ON THE PHONE.
- LIZ, I DON'T WANT TO SAY
ANYTHING TOO EARLY,
BECAUSE, LIKE, I WANTED TO BE,
LIKE, A LADY ABOUT IT,
'CAUSE THAT'S, LIKE, MY VIBE,
BUT, LIKE, HONESTLY,
THE CAT'S, LIKE, PRETTY MUCH OUT
OF THE BUN, AND, LIKE...
- WHAT?
- I'M PREGNANT.
- WHA--
THAT'S AMAZING.
- THANK YOU.
- I'M LIZ.
MY BODY'S CHANGING,
AND SO ARE MY PRIORITIES.
- AND I'M LIZ.
IF I HAVE TO DO ALL THE WORK,
THEN I'M NOT GOING
TO WORK AT ALL.
I'M THE BIGGER ONE.
- AND THIS IS TEMPORARY.
OUR P.R. FIRM
IS CALLED PUBLIZITY.
[both slurping]
- IT'S BASED OFF OUR NAMES.
- YOU HAVE MILK VOICE.
- SHUT UP, LIZ.
- I'M KEEPING IT THIS TIME.
- AMAZING.
- THANK YOU.
- O.M.G., I'M SORRY.
I DIDN'T REALIZE
YOU COULD GET PREGNANT FROM
A GUY BLASTING ON YOUR STOMACH.
I'M TRYING TO THINK
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT GUYS
THAT HAVE PROBABLY [bleep]
ON YOUR STOMACH
THAT YOU WOULD THEN SCOOP
THAT [bleep] INTO YOUR VAGINA,
LIKE, USING A PIECE OF PAPER
OR, LIKE--
- WELL, THAT WOULD BE, LIKE,
AN ALTERNATIVE LIST,
BECAUSE, LIKE, THIS TIME,
THE FELLOW,
LIKE, ACTUALLY,
LIKE, LOOKED ME
RIGHT INTO MY FACE,
AND, LIKE, WHEN HE SAW MY FACE,
THAT'S EXACTLY THE MOMENT THAT,
LIKE, HE SHOT UP HIS STUFF,
LIKE, RIGHT INSIDE
OF MY THING.
THE FATHER OF THE BABY
IS A TOILET BABY, C-CZAR,
AND, LIKE, I DON'T CARE
WHO KNOWS THAT,
EXCEPT FOR, LIKE,
MOST OF THE PEOPLE THAT I KNOW.
LIKE, I DON'T WANT THEM
TO KNOW,
'CAUSE I'M, LIKE, HORRIFIED
BY IT
AND, LIKE, VERY EMBARRASSED.
CASSANDRA,
GIVE ME THE BUCKET.
[breathes heavily]
[spits]
I JUST KEEP THROWING UP.
- ARE YOU SURE
THAT'S NOT SOME GUY'S...
- WHAT?
OH, THE STUFF?
WHO CAN NEVER BE SURE?
- ♪ EXTRAORDINARY
♪ GIRL